Donald Trump was confronted with more brutal
Cannes of block him up yesterday at a veterans
day parade.
It has not been so good for Donald Trump at
public events recently other than ones where
his audience is either handpicked, like at
rallies or in deeply parts of the country.
Like in Alabama over the weekend, Trump went
to game five of the major league baseball
world series in Washington DC a couple of
weeks ago.
He was met by just relentless booing and chance
of lock him up.
Last week he went to a UFC fight in New York
city.
Also met with relentless booing.
Then he went to a football game in Alabama
and actually got some cheers.
And then yesterday spoke at a veterans day
parade in New York city and it was ugly.
The crowd filled with signs like impeached
Trump signs that say trade or criminal lock
'em up.
And then of course the chance of lock him
up, lock him up a throwback by the eye.
I'm realizing that some people may not know
what lock him up stems from.
This is a throwback to the chance of lock
her up, referring to Hillary Clinton over
her emails, how quaint that seems.
Now during the 2016 Republican national convention,
you might remember a now indicted, uh, former
Trump national security advisor, Michael Flynn
was involved in leading a chant of lock her
up.
Uh, and we saw many others during the 2016
presidential campaign.
This is Trump's hometown, New York city, and
he's hated every public appearance is becoming
one of these.
Please clap moments for Donald Trump.
And let's be really honest about the true
incongruent CC of Trump speaking at a veterans
day parade.
I am hard pressed to think of a president
less supportive of our veterans than Donald
Trump.
He said he'd fix the VA and veterans health
care.
He's not done it.
He's attacked gold star families and gone
to war with the family of a of deceased military
captain.
Cause you're a con.
He attacked former prisoner of war, late Senator
John McCain.
He said that avoiding sexually transmitted
diseases from women he slept with was quote
his own personal Vietnam after getting a bogus
doctor's note to avoid going to the real Vietnam,
which by the way, I would've done the exact
same thing that was a completely pointless
and terrible military engagement.
That's actually not what's at issue here.
Trump wanted to use the military for his own
political gain by having them go guard the
border with Mexico during a completely fabricated
immigrant caravan crisis, which by the way,
who, whatever happened to that it's no longer
politically useful.
So it's simply not being mentioned, but expect
that it might, uh, experience a resurgence
as we get closer and closer to the November
of 2020 election.
He claimed to be donating money to veterans
charities, got the public relations benefit
of those donations, but then never actually
gave the money.
Aside from the fact that crowds are increasingly
hostile to Donald Trump, the guy has no business
whatsoever.
Speaking at a veterans day parade.
I can't think of, and I'm open to hearing
from you, is there any other president that
has been more hostile to the uh, military
and veteran community?
I can't think of one, at least not recently.